non
[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue au parlement européen
à bruxelles pour un nouveau numéro d'
europe hebdo émission spéciale cette
semaine avis de tempête sur la politique
agricole commune c'est une des
conséquences du break sites privés de
l'apport financier britannique l'europe
annonce sur une baisse du budget de la
politique agricole commune à la
commission européenne propose également
une pac plus décentralisée où les états
reprendrait un pouvoir de décision au
détriment de bruxelles
faut-il y voir les prémices d'un
détricotage de la pac un socle de
l'union européenne on va en débattre
avec nos invités marc tarabella bonjour
bonjour vous êtes député européen du
groupe des socialistes et démocrates à
eurodéputés de belgique membre de la
commission agriculture et si au
parlement européen merci d'avoir accepté
mon invitation julich de l'est
bonjour vous êtes députée européenne du
groupe du parti populaire européen
eurodéputée française membre des
républicains vous êtes aussi dans la vie
agricultrice merci d'avoir accepté mon
invitation enfin jean quatremer bonjour
vous êtes correspondant à bruxelles du
quotidien libération à vous animez aussi
le blog coulisses de bruxelles 1 pour ne
rien rater de l'actualité européenne
merci d'être venu semer d'abord pour
comprendre de quoi on parle retour sur
ces annonces de la commission européenne
sur la politique agricole commune
bruxelles redonne la main aux états pour
orienter leurs modèles agricoles et il
ya ces coupes un clair le budget de la
pac pourrait être amputé de 12% les
agriculteurs français devraient ainsi
renoncer à à 5 milliards dettes sur un
total de 55 milliards les explications
d'alice rougerie
moins d'argent pour l'agriculture en
europe
une première au sein de l'union le
budget de la politique agricole commune
va diminuer 365 milliards d'euros pour
la période 2021 et 2027 contre 408
milliards précédemment
le parlement européen parle d'une baisse
concrète de 15% la pac perd sa place de
premier budget de l'union
deux explications à cette coupe
budgétaire le bric citent d'abord sans
le royaume uni ces 10 milliards d'euros
annuels d'eads en moi et puis le rap a
aussi d'autres priorités aujourd'hui
défense sécurité immigration
il faut rééquilibrer les budgets ou bien
donner plus d'argent il y a plusieurs
façons d'éviter ces coupes la première
c'est que les états membres mettent plus
d'argent dans le budget unis ils
pourront discuter de cela dans les deux
prochaines années pour définir leur
politique
et s'ils ont l'impression que
l'agriculture est une priorité
importante comme il le laisse entendre
en ce moment je serai ravi de voir plus
d'argent à affluer et on pourra alors
revenir sur certaines couches sauf qu'en
attendant il faut bien trouver une
solution réunion informelle des
ministres de l'agriculture de l'union
européenne cette semaine
il n'accepte pas cette baisse la france
et l'espagne ont même présenté un
mémorandum exigent un budget pour la pac
au moins équivalent à celui
d'aujourd'hui nous ne baisserons pas les
bras et nous avons besoin de cette pac
non pas pour ce soir un complément de
rémunération mais parce que notre
agriculture française en particulier a
besoin de se transformer en profondeur
il n'y a pas que la baisse du budget qui
coince deuxième point de litige la
renationalisation de la pac
le projet prévoit en effet plus de
souplesse pour la distribution des aides
en clair ce n'est plus bruxelles qui
impose mais chaque état qui décide et
adapte danger selon certains qui met en
garde
la politique agricole commune doit
rester comme une renationalisation
ferait qu'on pourra avoir la mise en
oeuvre des objectifs européens à
géométrie variable direct dans un pays
ce serait le cas de la france
on serait très strict sur par exemple
l'utilisation de produits
phytosanitaires prenant par exemple
diffusé comme exemple dans d'autres pays
on laisse couler c'est à dire qu'on
n'aurait pas les mêmes contraintes et au
final on our une distorsion de
concurrence avec nos paysans à nous qui
serait pénalisée par des contraintes qui
serait plus forte qu'ailleurs
pas de distorsion de concurrence ni de
renationalisation rassure la commission
il s'agit plutôt de répartir plus
équitablement les aides en privilégiant
petites et moyennes exploitations
agricoles
les négociations commencent le 18 juin
la réforme doit être approuvée avant les
élections européennes de mai 2019
angélique delahaye ces coupes claires
c'est une mauvaise nouvelle pour les
agriculteurs français
certains de vos confrères au groupe ppe
parle de hold up organisé par la
commission
c'est une évidence au moment où le
parlement vote en commission
environnement l'obligation de mettre des
moyens pour accompagner les agriculteurs
vers la double performance économique et
environnementale
on tire le tapis on leur retire les
chaînes et les moyens qui vont avec pour
arriver à transformer notre agriculture
et la rendre plus vertueux sur le plan
environnemental
donc c'est juste un mauvais coup et
novellus quoi concrètement les
conséquences pour l'agriculteur en saas
et une baisse l'une de baisse de la
contribution qui va lui qui lui est
apporté
et puis en france il ya quand même la
double peine parce que la france va
économiser le chèque britannique
elle va économiser 1 6 milliard d'euros
par an pourquoi ne leur met elle pas sur
le budget de la pac
je pense que l'effort n'est pas très
important puisque c'est déjà une dépense
qui dans le budget de la france
marc tarabella il ya ces restrictions
budgétaires il ya aussi cette
renationalisation de la pac 1 à des
piliers de la construction européenne on
redonne la main aux états pour orienter
leurs modèles agricoles c'est quoi ces
renoncements très clairement je pense
que l'europe n'a plus l'agriculture
comme étant une priorité depuis très
longtemps malgré que le budget reste
important même s'il diminue ce sera
quand même 30 % du budget européen
c'est pas rien mais quand on voit que
l'agriculture est souvent la variable
d'ajustement des autres politiques
lorsqu'il s'agit de faire des accords de
libre échange
lorsque l'on voit que l'on abandonne
tous les mécanismes de régulation qui
précipite les prix à la baisse et qui
donc rendre rendent moins je dirais
moins prospères les agriculteurs et
qu'en même temps ce ont fait la
concurrence notamment quand on sur
produit du lait par exemple prix diminue
et on fait la concurrence avec notre
lait en poudre dont on n'a rien à faire
en afrique dont l'ex porte en afrique et
ce sont les entreprises agroalimentaires
qui en bénéficient au détriment les
agriculteurs africains
on n'est pas logique on n'est pas
cohérent et donc moi je pense lille au
delà de la restriction budgétaire
l'agriculture et l'alimentation devrait
être une priorité européenne ne l'est
plus aujourd'hui il faut constater et le
regretté jean quatremer est ce que la
politique agricole commune la pac elle a
perdu ce sont ces les plus communes
ouais il ya deux choses soi-même
développer alors quand on qu'on vous dit
en présentant le sujet c'est une
conséquence du brésil
c'est pas vrai oui le brésil fait que on
perd un état membre et on perd entre 10
et 12 milliards de contributions nettes
1 c'est ça la différence en ce chrono de
paye la grande bretagne est ce qu'elle
reçoit chaque année au budget
communautaire
mais c'est un choix idéologique le choix
idéologique qui a été fait par la
commission c'est quoi c'est de ne pas
augmenter le budget communautaire
parce que je vous rappelle qu'en
septembre dernier jean claude juncker
lui même disait qu'il fallait passer le
budget communautaire à 1.20 du pib
communautaire 1.20 contre eux à peu près
1% aujourd'hui emmanuel macron été sur
cette ligne-là les allemands dans
l'accord de grande coalition était sur
cette ligne là et finalement la
commission a décidé de s'aligner sur les
moins disants européens que sont les
néerlandais les danois les finlandais
les suédois etc c'est un choix
idéologique qui a été fait par la
commission de se retirer des politiques
communes évidemment quand ce soit
idéologie qui a été prolongée sur un
petit gars école commune je vous
rappelle que la politique agricole
commune mais dans la soumission et
demande aux états de mettre un peu plus
d'argent sur le pot commun c'est ma
vraie ça reste à 1 le budget
communautaire va rester à 1.08
exactement du pays ptv communautaire y a
pas plus d'argent qui sera mis au pot
commun
en fait on répartit si vous voulez les
coupes c'est tout et alors je voudrais
vous dire comme sur la pac parce que
c'est symboliquement très important
pourquoi c'est la plus vieille politique
communautaire et c'est la seule 1957
voilà et surtout c'est la seule
politique communautaire qui est
totalement intégrée c'est-à-dire qu'en
réalité a quasiment plus de budgets
nationaux
donc c'est une politique industrielle
c'est à dire qui est géré en commun de
façon très fédéral et c'est pas hasard
c'est la commission table d'abord là
dessus c'est idéologique
c'est une approche de droite et c'est
une approche de droite libérale on
démantèle et on démentait ça va encore
plus loin parce que là une fois qu'on
l'a dit fait le choix de couper en plus
on redonne aux états le la liberté de
gérer comme à peu près comme ils
l'entendent
la politique agricole qui devient en
fait une sorte de dire on passe d'une
vision commune plutôt à une gestion
commune d'une enveloppe répartis par
bruxelles et à l'intérieur de cette
enveloppe ont fait à peu près ce qu'on
veut en clair moi je pense que dans dix
ou quinze ans
il n'y aura plus de politique agricole
commune pourquoi parce que tout
simplement à quoi ça sert d'avoir une
espèce de grande caisse de compensation
à bruxelles qui ne fait que re
distribuer des chèques
c'est le début de la fin et la
commission ne large et les malades c'est
le début de la fin ah oui chaque je
partage complètement ce que vient de
dire mon voisin c'est le début de la fin
on l'avait déjà senti dans la dernière
réforme pour moi était une réformette
on prétend de compagne et oui une telle
2013 on prétend accompagner
l'agriculture amis et une souveraineté
alimentaire qu'il faut qu'il faut qu'on
conserve enfin je pense qu'on vit comme
des excusez moi de le dire comme ça
comme des riches parce que il ya
profusion d'alimentation on a
l'impression que tout ça est éternelle
bien non alors si on n'est pas capable
d'accompagner notre agriculture est de
garder des prix à la consommation qui
sont ce qu'ils sont aujourd'hui
pourquoi on a des prix aussi bas en
consommation c'est parce que on
accompagne l'agriculteur dont ses coûts
de production
or on lui met des contraintes
supplémentaires et moi je les entends
ces contraintes il faut mieux intégrer
les questions environnementales dans nos
modes de production à ça fait 20 ans que
je me bats pour ça et c'est complètement
aujourd'hui intégré par l'agriculture
moi j'en ai un peu assez je l'aï déjà
dit sur ce plateau qu'on oppose
agriculture et environnement
les premiers écologistes sont les
agriculteurs
vous n'allez pas me faire croire qu'ils
sont là pour saccager leur outil de
travail
un agriculteur il est là de génération
en génération pour transmettre ses
terres il a aucun intérêt à le faire
quelquefois on l'a fait par manque de
connaissance par manque de formation des
agriculteurs
aujourd'hui un jeune qui s'installe il a
fait des études il a des formations
agronomique et donc il est parfaitement
en capacité de faire ça donc on re il
faut vraiment que ce qu'a dit jean
claude juncker à l'occasion son discours
sur l'état de l'union en 2016 devienne
une réalité
nous ne pouvons pas perdre la bataille
de l'alimentation et d'un drop juste je
rappelle au passage que l'agriculture
c'est ce qui a motivé c'est à dire donc
l'alimentation c'est ce qui a motivé la
plupart des guerres dans le monde et le
pourquoi est ce que l'allemagne est un
pays apaisé aujourd'hui en grande partie
grâce à la politique agricole commune je
rappelle qu'elle est devenue pour la
première fois de son histoire
autosuffisante alimentairement en 1966
grâce à la politique agricole commune
or jusqu'à présent l'alma
avait fait des guerres et de guerre
mondiale quand même 70 millions de morts
au passage pourquoi parce qu'elle
n'arrivait pas à assurer sa propre
subsistance jouer avec l'agriculture
s'est joué avec l'apc jouer avec le
projet européen
moi je trouve ça incroyable que les gens
à l'agglo ici on affaiblit la pas qu
enfin nous on affaiblit l'europe on
favorise nationalise et c'est le retour
des chocs des nations je pense qu'il n'y
a plus personne qui réfléchit au sein de
cette commission européenne c'est un
drame veut dire que quelqu'un comme
comme celle mayer qui sont le secrétaire
général quitte à la commande c'est jean
claude juncker aujourd'hui quasiment à
la retraite mais quelqu'un comme c'est
le meilleur c'est un panel n'est pas élu
il est fonctionnaire bien sûr c'est un
mal à l'europe comme personne ne l'a
fait avant lui alors elle est quand même
sous le feu des critiques quand même la
pac les états disait la pac c'est trop
compliqué les agriculteurs disait je
suis pas c'est pas la cgc la
mondialisation et la société civile
disait que la pratique n'est pas assez
respectueuse de l'environnement et de la
santé
est-ce qu'il fallait pas changer de
modèle marc tarabella mais si clairement
mais malheureusement la commission
ultralibérale et les états membres
majoritaire vont dans le même sens
le rouleau compresseur continue est donc
aujourd'hui on ne protège plus le revenu
de l'agriculteur et les aides de la pac
ne suffisent plus accorder un revenu
décent aux agriculteurs puisque on
dérégule tout les politiques
donc c'est évidemment un gros problème
on est aussi je ne dis pas cohérent par
rapport
quand on veut mettre en regard la
politique environnementale appétit
agricole on pourrait redistribuer les
aides de manière encore plus à aider
l'agriculture qui est respect le plus
respectueux de l'environnement
pas seulement l'agriculture bio il ya
aussi des agriculteurs qui travaillent
en agriculture raisonnée et on ne le
fait pas on ne veut vraiment pas au
niveau européen et je le répète
aujourd'hui on a un problème
l'argent doit aller pour la politique de
défense et pour la politique des
migrants qui ont encore pas assurée au
niveau européen
2 millions de migrants mais si on
continue ses politiques de dérégulation
ou l'alimentation est évidemment au
centre des priorités partout dans le
monde
eh bien on risque effectivement d'avoir
une grosse renationalisation de la pac
et plus d'autosuffisance alimentaire
européenne et on organise la dépendance
alimentaire aux marchés internationaux
en afrique et bien continuer à faire ça
il y aura par deux millions de migrants
dans quelques années il y aura des
migrants effectivement économique parce
que leurs terres
devenu infertiles et deux n'ont pas
d'autre choix que de la quitter il y en
aurait des dizaines de millions et quand
on voit les refoulés on va dresser des
murs de 10 mètres de haut c'est tout à
fait incohérent jo bruxelles affirme
vouloir faire mieux avec moins d'argent
c'est possible on va écouter fars moi je
chante en maîtres mots de la commission
européenne ces simplifications pas je
suis désolé le schéma qui nous est
proposé c'est quoi ça se résume à quoi
pour moi ve agricultrice
c'est un projet qui va être défini par
des technocrates administrés par des
fonctionnaires nationaux arbitré par les
fonctionnaires européens
si c'est ça qu'on appelle la fonte la la
simplification administrative
moi je considère qu'aujourd'hui la pac
elle est encore plus technocratique
qu'hier et donc moins politique et que
qu'elle va être mais revient largement
de l'air et dans la rade lier les aides
directes aux agriculteurs premier pilier
et al 2000 il ya le 2e pilier le
développement cirad et chaque état va
pouvoir faire ce qu'il veut des deux
piliers est ce qu évoqué un instant marc
tarabella sur la transition et
l'accompagnement vers une agriculture
plus responsable sur le plan
environnemental
on l'a votée on a voté un programme
qu'on appelle et costumes en commission
environnement qui permettait de mettre
en place des nouveaux outils on a dit il
faut que les états consacrent au minimum
30% pour cette accompagnant vers la
double transition et la double
performance est bien café la commission
elle dit bah les états font ce qu'ils
veulent ils font de 0 à 100 possibles
je me précisait un petit peu ce que vous
avez dit ce passe comment ça va se
présenter aujourd'hui il va y avoir neuf
objectifs généraux les objectifs faut
les voir un c'est du style assurer un
revenu décent aux agriculteurs
respecter l'environnement etc et dans
lequel ses objectifs donc chaque état
aura une enveloppe budgétaire et chaque
état viendra à bruxelles pour négocier
avec bruxelles un programme national
respectant ses objectifs et on va dire
voilà je respecte tel ou tel objectif
pour qu'on parle de bureaucratisation
confirmé au bout de huit mois par la
commission oui mais voilà la commission
et donc on négocie donc ça va être le un
bureaucrate du ministère de
l'agriculture français on prend le cas
de la france il viendra à bruxelles
négocier avec un bureaucrate de la
commission européenne et c'est le
bureaucrate de la commission européenne
qui a trait à terme vérifiera
l'application l'application de ce fameux
programme
je vous rappelle quand même
pour vous montrer assez pour la
décentralisation un peu de dire sa
politique agricole commune vous soyons
sérieux aux nationalisations à soyaux
soyons sérieux
la commission devrait embaucher
peut-être un million d'auditeurs pour
vérifier que ça se passe bien sur le
terrain vous rendez compte qu'ils n'ont
pas été fichus de détecter que les grecs
menthe et sur leur budget et vous allez
me faire croire qu'ils vont être
capables de vérifier ce qui se passe
dans les montagnes corses il faut être
sérieux il y aura évidemment aucune
vérification une grande partie des états
membres alors ceux qui sont bien
administré comme la france par exemple à
une chance peut-être que ça soit à peu
près appliquée mais la bulgarie la
roumanie la pologne etc
vous oubliez donc en réalité la
commission s'en lave les mains pire ce
n'est même pas une pratique démocratique
parce que le co législateur dans cette
affaire là le parlement européen et le
conseil des ministres sont totalement
les gars et ils disent ils vont dire aux
des bars des paris vont accepter les
règlements donc voter les règlements
donc définissant ses grands objectifs et
on sait ensuite c'était un mini pendant
sept ans maintenant après vous êtes en
vacances c'est tranquille c'est clair
amamou oui je veux pour dire que la
commission va vraiment à rebours de ce
qui se fait partout dans le monde soit
plus peut ouvrir les yeux aussi ceci
fait dans le monde par tous les grands
acteurs agricoles recoupe les aides à la
réalité économique l'agriculture
sauf dans l'union européenne et dans
l'es9 mesure il autoriserait évidemment
plus de souplesse et un bon mot
souplesse ça passe bien pour ériger des
aides mais jamais vers des aides
couplées les aides couplées elles sont
minoritaires en europe mais elles
permettent de garder une agriculture
dans les territoires les moins
productifs c'est la prime à la vache
allaitante cela primes aux raisins secs
à corinthe c'est lié aux territoires
définis par les états et ça ils veulent
la supprimer le supprimer le seul outil
il permet de garder agriculteurs partout
ce territoire y compris dans les zones
les plus pauvres
il veut le supprimer dernier élément
regardons les effectifs dans les
différentes directions de la commission
européenne l'effectif à la direction de
l'agriculture a fondu et demain ça sera
la direction environnement
c'est la direction budget qui viendra
dicter à direction agriculture ce que
devront être les mesures pour
l'agriculture alors que les agriculteurs
et à la botte de businesseurope alors
les ministres de l'agriculture de
l'union européenne se sont donné rendez
vous mardi à sofia
ils se sont montrés très prudents sur
les propositions de la réforme de la pac
1 dévoilés par la commission et a même
des lignes rouges
on écoute quelques ministres de
l'agriculture à commencer par le
ministre irlandais très inquiet
franchement sur la pac
on est très préoccupée une mais pas
raisonnable de demander aux agriculteurs
de continuer à faire plus avec moins
d'argent
ça fait conscient que l'union européenne
a beaucoup de problèmes à gérer mais je
ne crois pas que ce soit une raison pour
réduire le budget de la politique
agricole commune dans le coin de rue de
belgique
on estime les coupes cumulées entre le
premier pilier
400 et 600 millions est très gros
efforts qui sont demandés à un certain
nombre de pays et la crainte que nous
avons c'est évidemment
l'agriculture continue qu'une forme de
variable d'ajustement du budget européen
et ça c'est difficilement acceptable
aujourd'hui nous sommes bien dans l'idée
de il faut transformer la pac il faut le
simplifier
il faut la rendre plus lisible pour nos
pour nos agriculteurs pour l'ensemble
des
nos concitoyens mais nous avons
aujourd'hui cette obligation que la pac
soit un véritable filet de sécurité pour
pour nos agriculteurs et donc nous
refusons
des cofinancements sur le premier pilier
c les choses sont claires
chez nous c'est une liste est une ligne
rouge pour pour la france
voilà on a entendu stéphane travert à la
ligne rouge le cofinancement c'est à
dire que les états mettent la main à la
poche pour la pax c'est ça qui fait peur
à la contribution nationale un
nécessaire pour pour compenser les
pertes
c'est pas ça qui devrait faire peur ce
qui devrait faire peur c'est la baisse
du budget l'aco le cofinancement aura
pour eux pour conséquence d'augmenter la
distorsion de traitement des
agriculteurs entre eux au plan européen
comment peut-on accepter sur un marché
unique de telles distorsions on les
dénonce déjà sur les aspects sociaux sur
les aspects environnementaux puisque
tous les agriculteurs européens ne sont
pas soumis aux mêmes règles dans ces
deux domaines d'activités
maintenant on va là croître on va
s'accroître de par même la politique qui
sont ces les gérer mais il faut signaler
pourquoi parce que en fait pour
cofinancer ça veut dire qu'il faut avoir
des moyens budgétaires
ses seuls moyens et c'est pour ça qu'une
partie par exemple des fonds structurels
ne sont pas utilisés parce que les états
les plus pauvres n'ont pas les moyens de
co-financer donc fou êtes vous donner
une prime aux états déjà les plus riches
et vous en revanche vous nuisez aux
états les plus pauvres comme le portugal
éventuellement l'espagne la grèce et les
tous les pays de l'est ces salles que
financement ou bien faut bien voir ce
que ça veut dire est vrai que
l'allemagne depuis 1999 et depuis
fraudeurs se bat pour le cofinancement
ils sont tout à fait pour parce qu'ils
ont tellement d'argent et sans surplus
budgétaires que ya aucun problème ils
peuvent financer tout seul l'agriculture
appuyé par les autres pays ce n'est pas
le cas donc on a vu ainsi ses mix de
l'agriculture ya quand même une ligue 1
contre les propositions de la de la
commission pensait que ça ça peut passer
vous disiez les états étaient plutôt
d'accord laissons plutôt pas d'accord
que l'on sorte des mini séries cultes de
plants sont des gouvernements européens
vont réagir
d'habitude c'est une machine à faire du
surplace conseil aujourd'hui quand
l'europe ne sait plus décidé de ne plus
de stratégie dans c'est que ça va être
retirée ce budget là avant les élections
européennes
non il a raison pour monde doit pas
l'être non plus à rien de précipiter de
réformes
une option il faut bien là réfléchir et
faire de la résistance par rapport à une
commission qui a manqué d'ambition
jean quatremer l'a rappelé par rapport
au budget notamment et les états membres
doivent revenir aussi à une ligne plus
ambitieuses pour toute une série de
politiques le président doit être une
opportunité de se recentrer sur des
politiques que l'on définit beaucoup
mieux ensemble est aujourd'hui en train
de de redistribuer vers les états
membres la responsabilité de faire
chacun chez soi ce qu'il veut et donc on
détricote la pac notamment mais c'est
vrai aussi dans d'autres politiques qui
ne sont pas intégrés
on n'a pas de stratégie européenne
détricote la paquet mais est-ce qu'il
faut pas réserver une part plus
importante du budget de l'union
européenne a d'autres priorités comme la
défense la crise migratoire la sécurité
intérieure et extérieure
les nouvelles technologies je le répète
une nouvelle fois la politique agricole
commune consomme une part importante du
budget parce que c'est la seule
politique
si demain on mutualiser l'ensemble des
budgets de la conférence sort du hadj et
voilà si demain on mutualiser l'ensemble
des budgets de la défense européen ça
serait 95 % du budget c'est simple voilà
faut comprendre les choses
il faut arrêter avec ce truc populiste
et de dire à regarder il ya 30 % de
l'argent européen qui va l'agriculture
une et parce qu'elle n'a quasiment plus
dans les budgets nationaux
on a mutualisé on à fédéraliser les
budgets nationaux ce n'est juste
rebondir sur ce que sur ce que vous
venez de la question vous avez posé sûr
on va aboutir d'ici juin 2019
ça montre aussi dans le monde irréel
dans lequel vit la commission européenne
qui souhaite effectivement qu'on
aboutisse au mois de mai c'est à dire au
moins d'un an d'abord ça s'est jamais
produit une négociation budgétaire de
cette importance là teclaw qui se
clôture au bout d'un an et surtout pour
abréger à 2021 et 2027 voilà le milieu
tony blair a pris 13 mois et vous irez
vous imaginez vous imaginez que donne
surtout nous à perdre donc demain vous
allez par exemple en france si on
n'arrive pas à augmenter le budget donc
en marche va faire une campagne avec un
budget agricole en diminution mais les
populistes l'extrême droite les
fascistes vont être ravis ça va donner
des arguments évidemment à l'opposition
ça sera pareil dans tous les pays
personne n'a intérêt à conclure avant
évidemment dire que la commission puisse
penser qu'on puisse liquider une
discussion de cette envergure là et ce
soir nous a quittés le démantèlement de
la politique agricole commune dans
l'espace de dix mois mais ils vivent
dans un monde bien ils sont à disneyland
l'admission des libraires ce coup de
rabot ça va encore favori jean quatremer
ça va favoriser les populistes d'autant
que les extrêmes ce en europe dans le
monde rural kiwi qu'on les trouve donc
là on leur donne on leur fait un
boulevard
je vois là franchement moi qui suis
resté agricultrice que je suis la moitié
du temps quand je suis pas là sur mon
exploitation je vois les réactions sur
le terrain mes voisins exploitants c'est
quoi
mais si non mais qu'est ce que c'est que
cette europe elle est là pourquoi nous
ne parons construit la politique
agricole commune
si aujourd'hui l'agriculture française
est ce qu'elle est c'est bien grâce à
l'europe
donc est ce que l'europe veut nous tuer
si c'est ça on n'a aucune raison d'aller
voter pour les partis qui nous propose
la construction la poursuite de la
construction européenne telle que partie
des républicains
allez on passe à notre rubrique de fact
checking à stéphane travert ministre de
l'agriculteur encore lui affirme qu'il
n'existe aucune étude prouvant la baisse
du nombre d'abeilles
at il raison ces checkpoints préparer
aujourd'hui par adeline noviny
[Musique]
nos populations d'abeilles domestiques
sont elles en train de décliner depuis
plusieurs années apiculteur et amoureux
de la nature tire la sonnette d'alarmé
nos abeilles vont mal cette année c'est
même une hécatombe en bretagne plus de
la moitié des abeilles domestiques n'ont
pas passé l'hiver
pourtant quand on demande au ministre
français de l'agriculture ce qu'il
compte mettre en place pour aider des
apiculteurs
ils nous répondent les dispositifs de
surveillance dont disposent les pouvoirs
publics aujourd'hui ne permettent pas à
cette heure de corroborer une
généralisation de cette dégradation
donc selon les chiffres officiels les
populations d'abeilles domestiques ne
serait pas en déclin dans l'hexagone
pour vérifier ça regardons l'évolution
du nombre de ruches française on observe
une forte chute début des années 2010
depuis leur nombre se stabilise ces
chiffres ne permet toutefois pas de
connaître l'état de santé des abeilles
pourquoi parce qu'un apiculteur est
avant tout un éleveur quand il subit des
pertes
il remplace ses colonies il faut donc
s'intéresser aux pertes de colonies et
la réalité est un peu plus difficile à
cerner le problème est qu'il n'existe
pas de système de surveillance de la
mortalité des abeilles au niveau
national mais l'on peut quand même avoir
une idée de la situation
l'aca plusieurs études scientifiques
financés par les pouvoirs publics
français et européens
tout montre un taux de mortalité trop
élevé les apiculteurs ne reconnaissent
ils peuvent accepter de perdre 10% de
leurs colonies
mais c'est un maximum or depuis 2006 ce
seuil est systématiquement dépassé de
manière plus ou moins importante
mais abbey françaises ne sont pas au top
de leur forme cette situation
inquiétante ne concerne pas que la
france la belgique la suisse ou encore
l'espagne ont dépassé les 20 % de
mortalité l'hiver dernier en allemagne
ce chiffre a même atteint les 30% alors
quand stéphane travert déclare que les
dispositifs de surveillance des pouvoirs
publics ne permettent pas de montrer un
déclin des populations d'abeilles
c'est contestable voilà pour le
checkpoint à vous le constatez angélique
delahaye ce ce déclin des abeilles
c'est quelque chose qui est très
variable d'une région à l'autre
je pense qu'il faut mettre ça en lien
des insectes
ma mère précise est indispensable à
calais il a condamné la décision tueur
pour la pollinisation et donc pour la
production d'un certain nombre de
d'espèces végétales
moi je produis des légumes il n'y a pas
de pollinisateurs pour les salades mais
bon pour autant je constate
effectivement que les choses sont
extrêmement variables mais il y aurait
des mesures très simples à prendre on
sait on sait que cette mortalité
elle est multifactoriel elle dépend de
l'affectation des cheptels avec 7,1 ce
parasite qu'est le varois
elles dépendent de la formation des
apiculteurs et le dépend de la capacité
à créer des réserves de nourriture pour
les abeilles
moi j'essaye de matt mohebbi maintenant
j'essaie de me battre dans mon
département pour que une partie des
accotements de nos routes
départementales soit mise en ondes
mellifères pour que candeur mellifères
ça permet la nourriture des abeilles et
donc la production du miel
d'accord ce sont ce sont des mixtes de
de fleurs permettent aux abeilles de se
nourrir
donc je crois qu'il faut faut pas être
catégorique faut être très pragmatique
liés à la mortalité des abeilles ça
personne ne peut le nier elle est
variable d'une région à l'autre d'une
année à l'autre
une période de l'année à l'autre de moi
en ce moment chez moi y avait plein de
colza mais nicollin ne sont plus en
fleurs tant que les abeilles et ben sont
beaucoup moins à manger qu'avant donc on
arrive et on arrive à la fin de cette
émission le mot de la fin sur cet avis
de tempête dans la politique agricole
commune
ah ben c'est il va falloir que les états
soient pour une fois plus ambitieux que
la commission jusqu'à présent la
commission a toujours été beaucoup plus
ambitieuse que les états c'est un vrai
recul de la seule institution j'aurai
des communautaires quasi fédéral de
l'union européenne il ne joue plus son
rôle avec thé aux états et notamment à
la france l allemagne est bien de
montrer la voie et de réagir face à cet
abandon de l'esprit communautaire
rapidement j'espère que le parlement
jouera son rôle océans et une majorité
très forte pour résister face à ce
détricotage annoncée de la pac en fin de
run europe hebdo à merci à vous
de nous avoir suivis merci à vous trois
d'être venus débattre à la semaine
prochaine vous retrouvez n'aura hamadi
d'ici là bonne suite des programmes sur
les chaînes parlementaires et la rtbf
bail
[Musique]